Joe rogan podcast by night all day Weidman was pressing him,
but Anderson was kicking him a lot in the legs and I was looking.
I was like,
Ooh,
like he's kicking his legs a lot.
He did a lot of times,
like crazy taunting,
but you know what?
Weidman did something really slick.
He did something really slick.
It's really interesting.
He threw a back fist,
he threw a punch and then he threw a back fist because they understand what's
going on.
He was bobbing and weaving and bobbing and weaving,
moving away from.
So he figures if the rights coming in the left's comment,
so he throws a punch.
Mrs then throws it back fist,
which makes Anderson have to go that way.
Right?
So then when he starts going that way the other way and catches him with a left
hook,
it's a.
it's a beautiful combination.
It's a beautiful combination with a guy,
moves his head a lot because you forced them because you're not just throwing
one in that direction.
You throw in a second one,
so he's going that way,
which is like when you throw a left hook,
he's going that way,
so he's already going the way to avoid the left hook.
He's got to come back and when it comes to when it comes back,
boom.
He catches him.
Perfect.
He was like,
it's brilliant.
Beautiful Time.
It's the setup before the fucking blow to it looked a little slower than
Anderson,
so he was having a hard time catching them and they understand was staying on
the outside and kicking his legs a lot.
But they had collided in the first round and he took anderson down and wrapped
one of his legs up and had them pretty tight.
It's like you might be getting a leg lock or attempting to leg lock and Anderson
got out of it.
Isn't that the fight to where at the,
after the fight where Weidman was like,
make your decision now you're either on board or you're not.
I think there was no,
that was another fight.
Another fight.
Yeah.
I think that was,
um,
that was after vituro sick after he beat up beat tour.
He's like,
pick your title.
Yeah.
I was like,
well,
I'm bored.
I was like,
Damn Chris,
you've had up to now to decide.
Pretty good.
Yeah.
You know,
he's an interesting guy.
He takes a loss like a fucking champ.
I'll tell you that.
He lost till Yoel Romero by knockout and then the was sitting on the das
entering questions later with this aisle all stitched up.
You know what I mean?
He's a,
he's a,
uh,
he's a stud.
You know,
if I was hard to do man.
Oh,
I bet.
Kao.
And then just answer,
answer questions with stitches over your eye and you're talking to press people.
I've seen some guys real fucked up at perfect composure though.
You handled it perfectly.
That was at that Gustafson,
Jon Jones fight where they,
I think they both went to the hospital.
It was brutal.
Brutal,
brutal fight where it was a decision.
Fine,
I think.
Yeah.
Then it was like the,
like they just massacred each other,
you know,
they're just beat the shit out of each other.
That was a crazy fight.
Yeah.
That was a fight where John was talking about it when he was on the podcast was
talking about how much he partied after that fight for the fight.
Partying a lot.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was incredible fight.
I just remember her bloodied.
Those guys were.
Yeah.
It was a rough fight.
Gustafson shocked.
A lot of people.
Yeah.
That's the crowd.
You could feel the crowd swell.
What I always call mma,
this is the phrase I use all the time,
so maybe it'll start getting annoying too.
It's like extreme problem solving with dire physical consequences.
That's why it's plus shit talking.
Right?
Throwing that to high stakes talking shit.
Yeah.
High stakes.
There's an emotions battle whether or not you can keep your emotions.
How will you handle pressure?
That's giant.
That's the thing about conor mcgregor more than anything.
Like,
Nah,
we shouldn't say more than anything.
It's one of many things about them.
That's pretty interesting.
One of the most interesting things about him as he handles pressure like nobody
I've ever seen.
Yeah.
Like when he fought Aldo for the title,
he didn't even look remotely nervous.
He was super relaxed,
super calm,
but then you start to think though that you go,
how much of what you're seeing is how pressure is manifested through that guy.
You know what I mean?
Like for instance,
the press conference kind of antics.
You're like,
is that,
is that genuine?
Is that an act?
Is that how he handles the pressure of this high pressure situation by doing a
fucking,
you know,
Bang,
Bang show at the time.
So like it.
But I personally,
I find the guy,
which is,
I think what you want,
why someone becomes a star,
a endlessly entertaining on top of being good.
So I,
you know,
I'm tuning into,
I want to see the fucking show.
He's the best shit talker of all time.
I don't know.
I've said that before about other people before that I said Chael Sonnen was the
best shit talker of all time and I think he was for awhile,
but I think Connor Thompson and also all also as well.
Connor has an additional significance to a shit-talking because he knocked
people dead.
Right?
It's a totally different thing.
And,
and not that he's not a fucking animal because Chael Sonnen is an animal and
he's,
he's submitted Shogun who a shell ends,
a very solid grappler,
sure came very close to beating Anderson Silva in their first fight.
So He's a stud.
But what connor does differently is the isis guys with one punch,
and that's a big factor in fight when you're watching him and he fights Eddie
Alvarez and all of a sudden he things and with the lefthand and catches them a
rock some early on you go,
Holy Shit.
And he realized he's fighting the guy now at 155 pounds.
And Eddie Alvarez a big one,
55.
He's a big guy,
big muscular guy.
The idea is that he's gonna be able to wrestle connor.
He's going to be able to grab them and grind them out the same way you did with
Anthony Pettis.
Nope.
Dealing with a totally different animal.
Connor's just got a totally different kind of focus as far as like the way zooms
in on targets and his precision.
It's just speed.
He's just dropping it in there with a 100 percent speed,
like that's a big part of what he's doing.
He's not loading up at all and the ability to stay calm when you load up,
say like if you see someone coming at you and you just go like,
all that's wasted time that's wasted time with connor has is the ability to be
perfectly technical in a firefight.
So like Aldos.
Yeah,
charging Adam.
This is like 13 seconds into the fight.
All those charts and Adam and he knows how to just slide back and blam drops
that lefthanded in on it is a striking.
The strongest part of his.
Yes,
for sure.
His ground game is underrated.
He's very good on the ground.
This was very good.
Defensively.
He's got a good sweep sweep.
Nate Diaz.
Their first people forget that.
He's the kind of guy.
How much would you love to watch before he was a professional?
I did watch them.
Well,
not before the bar fights though.
Oh Geez.
You know,
he's been in some definite scrap bars,
but I don't think you're allowed to like get 18 in Ireland.
If you haven't been in a bar fight.
Yeah man,
we're going out tonight lead when you're chatty.
That's probably the worst accent ever.
Probably right up there.
But um,
I saw them fight in a
cage warriors.
I tweeted to him in like 2013 before he came to the UFC.
I said,
I'm a big fan man.
Want you to come over and diddy?
Yeah.
I mean like,
right after that.
Um,
the uh,
you have seen him.
Totally coincidentally.
I didn't cry.
I mean,
I definitely probably told anybody listen to me about,
because I'd seen him fight before.
I'm like,
this kid.
Isis people.
Yeah.
His lefthand,
it's just devastating.
And he's got a crazy style.
He fights.
It was like wide stance and he moves different and he cracks guys.
I'm like,
this kid's legit.
I'd like to see him in the UFC.
I never asked you there.
Yeah,
that's January of 2013.
So it was almost four years ago.
Did you,
did you think,
uh,
I never talked to you about what did you think of all the,
um,
you know,
the talks of a him floyd mayweather fight.
You fight them.
I guarantee you he would fight if you think,
what kind of match do you think that he's a lot bigger than floyd?
First of all,
let's,
let's just emphasize that he's a lot bigger,
so it'd be a real problem as far as like weight cutting because if they went,
layla conor fight it wherever he wants.
Connor's is going away somewhere around 170 pounds.
Right.
That's where he's at his best.
Like in his optimum with no weight cutting.
Yeah.
I don't think Floyd's that big.
I think floyd,
I guarantee you he's probably not more than one 60.
Do you think Floyd's bigger than 1:16.
Real life.
Small Dude.
He's a small guy.
He's really nice.
Short doesn't mean wait,
but he's small.
What weight did he begin his career at?
Floyd Mayweather.
I mean,
I'm a huge floyd mayweather fan and I think that when it comes to boxing,
I think he's one of the most skillful boxers that's ever lived.
I really do technical,
if not the most 1:50.
But uh,
that's probably what he lasts.
Fought at like didn't he make 'em when he met,
when he fought Canelo didn't you make him come down a bit and made them come
down to like 1:54 or something like that?
It sounds right.
Something like that.
I thought they had some sort of a catch weight fight.
I remember.
And Canelo's fight.
Nobody's fighting at one 60 now.
He's definitely bigger.
Or was he fighting at 1:54?
Kinetica Lufkin is one 60,
right?
Is that the.
Hold up is the two of them because I think I feel like Canelo has been fighting
middle way too.
Like he fought Kodo.
What was that?
That
wasn't that at middleweight or 1:54?
Alvarez.
Alvarez catch weight 1:50 1:52.
Okay.
Yeah.
So he made canelo loose some weight.
He just.
Canal is a lot bigger than him.
Yeah.
So canal probably walks around maybe 20 pounds heavier than that.
That's a bad motherfucker too.
He's good.
Yeah.
And me that just boxed him up yet.
What I'm hearing plot all look at that.
Just beautiful technique that's wonder,
um,
could,
uh,
is,
is like connor's skills,
just technical skills match up to somebody like the counter counter defense.
I can't imagine they would unless they were there.
So out of shape.
Yeah.
Him,
I'm saying on top of his game,
him on top of his game,
you're not going to hit him.
He's going to know.
I mean you have to be really top level to catch him.
It's so nuts at that dude is so fast that he,
he box it like nobody's,
uh,
with his lead hand down.
Not even hip level.
Mid Thigh sometimes.
Well it's because that forces his shoulder over.
It's actually an easier way to block a lot of things.
If you're skillful with it.
You got shoulder.
Heck yeah.
You got to be.
It's not just quick.
And he's definitely quick.
It's very quick.
But what floyd has over,
like almost anyone else,
he said he's got this incredible knowledge of what you're going to do before you
do it.
Like he knows so much about boxing,
about boxing as a science from his brother or his father rather.
And his uncle,
his uncle's Roger May,
whether it was a black Mamba who an all time fucking exciting guy to watch.
And like the eighties and nineties,
he would starched people,
man,
dude him on those hbo shows.
They've never had a better comedy than Roger May.
Whether moments.
It's the greatest.
Oh,
you mean in between corners?
No,
when they used to do the 24 slash seven,
24 slash seven,
he would fucking massacre lowe's.
The funniest shit I've ever seen.
And they edited him.
So fucking funny.
One of those fights there were fighting,
maybe it was Alvarez or somebody.
And I was like,
we got to prepare for Florida and watch his fights.
And uh,
and I'm just,
I know I'm just going to have the fight in my life on my hands.
And then they cut to Roy or to,
to Roger Mayweather.
He goes,
who the fuck is Albert is
like,
he was pretending he doesn't even know who the guy
was.
You know that that was a big part of the preparation for.
I don't know if it in the end it was,
but for a long time when they would go like,
how are you preparing for this fighter?
His,
his answer and they're legit answer was like they have to prepare for this shit.
We're not preparing for anything.
He better prepare a lot you.
And that's how they would approach
it.
Like,
we're not studying you.
You need to study this shit right now because it's going to be bad.
What happens to you?
That was points.
Yeah,
it's a good point.
You know,
Floyd's an interesting guy.
He's had his hands broken a bunch of times.
Yeah.
Is.
There's been rumors about like fights that he must have had a broken hand in.
Oh,
he has had hands that were broken and he's still boxed that.
What does that feel like?
As soon as just got a winner's mentality,
you know,
you can talk all the shit you want about that guy because it's fun to talk shit
about him because you've created this persona that started in May.
Whether it's brilliant,
it's a brilliant thing.
What he did is brilliant.
He created like someone to hate,
but he's so talented.
You can't beat them and you're.
And you're buying that pay per view,
which is exactly what you want.
You're hoping cutting added.
Oh,
police Canada,
they're hoping Canelo can catch them at their home pack.
Yogurt category.
Everyone.
Yeah.
There's a guy that he craves the villain.
Keep going down the line.
Every fucking guy he's fought.
Please catch them.
Maybe you know you,
you saw with my own Marquez,
he had a tough fight with PAC.
Yeah.
Shuts them down overnight and then he'd be like,
I got 100 watches man.
And then that shuts them all down.
People like,
they really fucking.
I don't hate at all.
I think that it's a.
sometimes that persona can just get kind of boring.
It's fun.
Smart is it?
I'm like,
alright man,
just.
I'm saying like Instagram,
he's like,
look it up on my bed
and he'll be like,
you don't have a good night.
I'm going to count it,
and then it's hilarious.
It's funny,
it's entertaining,
but it is like one note he used to hold like bricks and money up to his ear
phone.
Pretend he's talking on the money.
Larry's cars.
Exactly.
Ridiculous cars.
They're all white too.
He's got like bugattis and shit.
Basically three,
Jesus Christ.
Oh my goodness.
What is that $100 million dollars that he got from what was just purse from one
of his fights.
He was a promoter.
He made a $100.
Million dollars is where hip hippies start going crazy about income inequality.
There's a sense.
Look at it as he goes.
This is just one of my many checks.
Got To love these backseat drivers.
So worried about hipaa school where you're going,
yeah.
Got To love these backseat drivers,
so worried about another man's legacy instead of trying to write their own.
Ultimately I will always have the last laugh.
This is just one of many checks.
Oh cool.
100 million dollars that I still have every dime of y'all still have to work.
However,
I'm happily retired.
At the end of the day,
it's them.
Benjamin Franklins at matter to me.
So the joke's on you.
I've made smart investments.
Sorry for those who thought that I couldn't read,
write or count.
Here we go.
Y'All call them.
Watch as I call them.
Time pieces.
Y'All call them bullets.
I called them yachts.
Y'all call them houses.
I call them manch.
What?
What does that mean?
Y'All chartered jets and we own jets.
The money team.
There you go.
Yeah,
I got it.
I think he's rich.
I think he definitely has money,
so he's made a lot of fucking money,
that's for damn sure.
He's excellent at what he does for sure.
Across the board.
Yeah.
I mean there's no doubt about it,
but he's also.
It's funny,
he's 49 and 49 slash 11 and he's the only guy.
He said he hasn't broken rocky Marciano's record yet.
He's tied it,
which is really interesting.
Like I wonder if that's on purpose.
I wonder if he doesn't want to break it.
Well,
I think as well people talking shit about the pressure of a of a,
of it going away is the thing that happens.
Like as the older you get,
like,
you know what I mean?
This is,
this is a good boxing retirement age for him and it's like,
do you want to do 50?
Yes.
Well it's got to be a meaningful 50.
You can't some scrub for 50.